welcome to Hannity and we start tonight
with a Fox News or four major breaking
stories we're covering
none of this news is good for the
Democratic Party the deep State or the
mob and the media now we start with this
massive news the deep state I guarantee
you this was leaked on purpose to get
ahead of what is coming and that is a
huge crisis because breaking just
moments ago another blow to the
Democrats impeachment charade
there is a report at this hour that an
FBI official is now under criminal
investigation for altering a document
related to the 2016 surveillance of the
Trump campaign advisor Carter page now
remember the FISA warrant against Donald
Trump campaign remember that was the
backdoor to get everything into all
things Trump campaign Trump transition
team Trump presidency now these reports
barring out well that would be called
FISA abuse exactly what we have been
exposing on this show for a very very
long time and now finally after years of
waiting thanks to the Horowitz probe now
at an end
justice is about to be served clearly
this is being leaked in advance to try
and get ahead of the report that Lindsey
Graham confirmed to us last night right
here on this program the FISA report
will come out on December the 9th
horowitz will testify before the Senate
Judiciary that's Lindsey Graham's
Committee on September on December the
11th we're going to continue to monitor
this developing story throughout the
hour Sarah Carter will break more news
on this in a minute
we're also tracking four other big
stories get this including another
disastrous day for the shift impeachment
coup attempt it was even worse believe
it or not than yesterday plus major new
information surrounding the Biden's
thanks to a letter from Senator Lindsey
Graham we have that letter we also have
a great new video you're going to want
to hit your record button tonight and
get this for well decades to come but
first we start in the Washington swamp
more hearsay more conjecture more
opinion and more arrogant bureaucrats oh
and an overheard phone call in a busy
restaurant that he ready for this was
not on speaker contradicting the person
that was actually on the private call
and the person was at the other end of
the table this is how bad this shift
show has now become it's so bad he even
presented a fact witness today with zero
facts none whatsoever
this was the ship shows grand finale
this was his closing argument and
today's hearing was supposed to tie
everything together instead again this
blew up right in shifts face and the
Democrats faces here's what Congressman
Jim Jordan said with the perfect summary
of the non case of the Democratic Party
against the President of the United
States take a look July 19 dr. hill
colonel vin Monteux Taylor what sahlan
told them July 19 sahlan told Taylor
about the upcoming Trump szalinski call
July 20th silent told Taylor what silent
old szalinski to tell Trump July 20th
dinah look tells Taylor what Zaleski
told Danny look July 28 Morrison tells
Taylor what happened on the Trump
Solinsky call August 16th Volker tells
Taylor what yaar Mac told Volker August
21st Brett ball talks to Taylor August
22nd Morrison talks to Taylor August
29th yaar Mack talks to Taylor September
1st Morrison tells Taylor what's onlin
told Morrison about what yaar Mack told
Sandling September 2nd Morrison tells
Taylor what Danny looked old Morrison
September 7th Morrison tells Taylor what
Soglin told Trump in September 8th Simon
tells Taylor what Trump told Sandlin all
right you follow that because that is
the Democrats case that's it in a
nutshell
that's supposed to be their compelling
evidence that's why they want to hurt
this country bring this country to the
brink of impeachment cuz they never got
over the fact that Donald Trump won the
election they never saw coming
the two witnesses today utter train
wrecks 1 a diplomat named David Holmes
he actually claimed this is not I'm not
making this up
that he overheard President Trump on a
phone call
talk about an investigation on the other
end of the phone call with Ambassador
Sunland while this guy was sitting
across the table from Sunland at a busy
loud restaurant and
call wasn't even on speaker Wow
super-hearing now Holmes did not hear
the entire conversation as testimony
contradicts what the guy actually on the
call said that was supposed to be
yesterday's star witness Gordon sunland
that's what the shifts show is now
reduced to the other witness from
today's hearing zero I mean zero
relevant facts
it wasn't even totally clear why she was
there and the opening statement falsely
accused Republicans of ignoring Russia
meddling and also falsely accused
Republicans of pushing a conspiracy
theory about Ukrainian election and
interference will somebody please give
her the January 11 2017 report at
politico.com about Ukrainian election
interference somebody needs to please
give her the Ukrainian courts own
findings that Ukraine did in fact
interfere in the 2016 elections to help
Hillary Clinton and hurt Donald Trump
now thankfully in a powerful moment well
this was really powerful congressman
Wenstrup well he set the record straight
take a look at this you know in 1998 I
voluntarily joined the United States
Army Reserve because I saw our country
under attack time and time again Bill
Clinton was the president I didn't vote
for Bill Clinton but he was my commander
in chief I'm grateful to live in a
country that gets to legitimately elect
our leaders and I've been to places
where people don't get to and it's not
pretty
dr. hill I'm sorry I have to say you
said based on statements you've heard
that some of this committee believe
Russia did not conduct a campaign
against our country is false
that's mr. Schiff narrative that's where
you've heard it we did a whole report on
it and we agree that Russia has done
this since the Soviet Union and they've
actually gotten better at it that's a
problem but at the same time certain
Ukrainians did work against candidate
Trump some with the DNC and if that's
debunked why is it mr. Schiff has denied
ENC operative alexandra chalupa from
testifying to come forward and debunk it
all right remember political reported
that chalupa Wow she was the DNC
operative remember she worked directly
with Ukrainian Embassy in Washington she
went there to collude to dig up dirt on
Hillary for Hillary Clinton and smear
Donald Trump and members of his campaign
team that would be called in my mind
collusion but today's witness a
so-called Ukraine expert knew nothing
about it
reporter cheryl atkinson formerly of CBS
News pointed out the idea that some of
our top experts on Ukraine are
closed-minded to this information and at
least once said he was entirely unaware
of it but we're making important
decisions could be considered disturbing
yeah you think this was probably the
biggest revelation out of the hearings
it has nothing to do with President
Trump and without a doubt the shift'
show is a giant failure dud but don't
take my word for it just listen to
former independent counsel Ken Starr he
thought yesterday oh this is gonna be
really a bad day for the Republicans and
President Trump he's now changed his
mind we're not in trial we're in a fat
gathering mode but what are we gathering
facts about and was there a crime and
then let's weigh this gravity and
seriousness of that crime does it reach
the level of treason bribery or other
high crimes and misdemeanors my
assessment of the evidence this for know
we're close the evidence is conflicting
and ambiguous conflicting ambiguous
nowhere close this is an absolute
unmitigated disaster now for the
Democrats now you have even the
compromised corrupt coward congenital
liar Adam Schiff guy that's lied to us
for three years he knows that this is a
disaster and he showed his anger
Republicans defeated the shift shows so
badly well as the Charlie Daniels song
says and the devil went down to georgia
and he knew he'd been beat and he laid
that golden fiddle on the ground at
Donald Trump's feet I guess in this case
he lost he knew it and by the way you
know before we show you this you have to
remember this is the guy the only person
on tape ever caught colluding with
somebody that he thinks is a Russian to
get compromising materials on Donald
Trump this isn't the first time this guy
got caught lying like he lied about oh I
have no idea who the whistleblower is
well I should have been honest about it
but no oh now I don't know about it by
the way one of my favorite tapes of all
time the very thing accusing Donald
Trump of with Russia he was guilty of
compromising materials listen the day
after Bob Muller testified the Donald
Trump invited Russian interference hey
Russia if you're listening
come get Hillary's emails and you can't
reveal you know I can't reveal that
Chris the other defense is the president
denies it we have not spoken directly
with the whistleblower Donald Trump is
back on the phone asking another nation
to involve itself in another US election
the nature of the comfor month well
there were pictures of naked Trump and
was made aware of the availability of
the compromising material yes of course
thank you very much we will be back in
touch we shouldn't really rely on what
the president said in the call record we
should imagine he said something else
and I'm gonna say this only seven times
so you better listen good I want you to
make up dirt on my political opponent
understand lots of it
compromise corrupt congenital liar he's
lied to the country for three years
three long years and ships closing
remark showed his rage now I'm sure if
it was up to him he'd just try and bring
in more hearsay witness's opinion
witnesses for I guess auditions first
depositions and then hearings but I
think Pelosi probably won't let him
remember she didn't want the ship show
to begin with it's been pretty clear her
priorities to get the hell out of this
mess as quickly as possible throw it to
the Senate as quickly as possible
placate her erratic
basse so she can remain speaker and name
only if Democrats they want to vote on
the House floor before Christmas well
that doesn't leave the compromise
congenital liar shift much more time to
do much more investigating so I had to
make a prediction tonight
I'd say the chief admits defeat spends
next week he'll draft ridiculous
articles of impeachment and send this
whole flaming bag of dog crap to the
Judiciary Committee around Thanksgiving
weekend
good luck turning that garbage into
something usable Jerry Nadler and on a
side note look at this now maybe shifts
ukrainian fantasy i can't believe it
might have been cooked up during his
taste of ukraine fundraiser that's right
the compromise congenital liar yeah he
had a fundraiser with a ukrainian
businessman you can't make that up and
at this point democrats the top allies
and the mob and the media they are
desperate these people are the same
people same liars same conspiracy
theorists same hoax spreaders if you
will
they've been lying to We the People now
for three plus years one hopes after
another one conspiracy theory after
another Russia Russia Russia impeach and
Peach impeach month-after-month every
second minute hour of any 24-hour day
predicting this is the president's
demise that is the president's to mine
this is a game-changer breathlessly
dramatically crying wolf for four years
now you may want to hit the record
button now because you're gonna want to
show this to your friends three two one
go I have not seen anything like this
since October 20th 1973 when President
Nixon fired Archibald Cox Nixon Richard
Nixon Watergate echoes of Watergate a
giant step toward impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment implications are
now in the air the president will be
removed from office a bombshell
bombshell bombshell bombshell bombshell
bombshell bombshell bombshell bombshell
stories dropping seemingly every day he
will resign the presidency warming to
the idea of his resignation he should
resign
I'm president sees the walls closing in
and is lashing out he feels the walls
closing in close again you could feel
the thread being pulled you can feel the
clothes starting to come off the Emperor
I believe this is the beginning of the
end Donald Trump's done he's done
there's no question about that 2016
after the election - all through 2017
all through 2018 and 2019 who would ever
trust these people what's not so
shocking tonight as Americans they have
now had enough of this if seeing through
this completely look at this new Emerson
poll a double-digit swing among
independent voters opposition in for
impeachment is now up a whopping 11
points Marquette University poll shows
the support for the impeachment has
dropped in the great swing state of
Wisconsin political poll shows that
voter support for impeachment is
declining nationwide now there are 330
million Americans just the tiny well
minor fraction have tuned into this you
know shift sham show and these hearings
and for good reason